>> Tucker: TWO WEEKS FROM NOW,
DNC DEPUTY CHAIRMAN KEITH
ELLISON MAY BECOME THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE OF
MINNESOTA.
THIS DESPITE ALLEGATIONS OF
ABUSE THAT HAVE BEEN LEVELED AT
HIM BY HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND, KAREN
MONAHAN.
KAREN MONAHAN IS A LIBERAL, SHE
IS A DEMOCRAT, BUT SHE HAS ALSO
COMPLAINED ABOUT THE POOR
TREATMENT SHE HAS RECEIVED FROM
FELLOW DEMOCRATS SHE WAS BOLD
ENOUGH TO GO PUBLIC WITH HER
ALLEGATIONS.
HAS ANYTHING CHANGED IN THE
WEEKS SINCE SHE SAID THAT?
KAREN MONAHAN AND HER ATTORNEY,
ANDREW PARKER, JOIN US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: KAREN, YOU SAID
PUBLICLY THAT SINCE COMING
FORWARD WITH YOUR CLAIMS AGAINST
KEITH ELLISON, THAT YOU WERE IN
EFFECT BLACKLISTED BY FELLOW
DEMOCRATS APPEARED CAN YOU
DESCRIBE WHAT YOU MEANT WHEN YOU
SAID THAT?
>> I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
SOCIAL MEDIA, IF YOU SEE SOME OF
THE LETTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN, THAT BASICALLY SAY THEY
DON'T BELIEVE ME.
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE SIGNED ON, IT
IS PRETTY APPARENT THERE HAS
BEEN A LOT OF
BULLYING, THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF HARASSMENT.
ISOLATION.
BY MANY FOLKS THAT I STOOD
SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH, SUPPORTING
THEM IN THEIR CAMPAIGNS, WALKING
WITH THEM IN VARIOUS PROTESTS,
WORKED TOGETHER ON DIFFERENT
ISSUES AROUND SOCIAL JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: THAT IS NOT THE
RECEPTION THAT PEOPLE WHO SAY
THEY ARE SURVIVORS OF ABUSE
EXPECT THEY ARE GOING TO GET
FROM THE LEFT, FROM DEMOCRATS.
WERE YOU SURPRISED BY IT?
>> NO.
I WATCHED THE #MeToo MOVEMENT,
I'VE WATCHED BOTH SIDES,
BASICALLY TAKE WOMEN'S PAIN AND
USE IT AS A TOOL FOR POLITICS.
AND ONCE IT CAME TO ONE SIDE OR
TO THE OTHER, YOU WOULD SEE THE
SAME PEOPLE START PUSHING AWAY
FROM IT AND SAYING STUFF LIKE,
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE REAL ISSUE
ISSUES.
THIS IS A REAL ISSUE.
>> Tucker: AND HER PARTNER, DO
YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATIC
ORGANIZATION IN MINNESOTA
INVESTIGATED THIS IN A
LEGITIMATE WAY?
THESE CLAIMS?
>> NO, IT WASN'T LEGITIMATE AT
ALL.
ANY OBJECTIVE REVIEW OF IT WOULD
REACH THE SAME CONCLUSION.
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE KICKED IT TO THE DFL
PARTY IN THE STATE OF MINNESOTA,
WHO HIRED THEIR LAWYER TO
INVESTIGATE THEIR CANDIDATE FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
NOT JUST THEIR CANDIDATE,
TUCKER, FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL,
BUT ACROSS THE LEFT, FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, A LEADER OF
THE PROGRESSIVE MOVEMENT, NOT
JUST IN MINNESOTA, BUT
NATIONALLY.
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE IS WHO THEY
WERE INVESTIGATING, AND THEY
HIRED THEIR OWN LAWYER, NOT AN
OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT LAWYER,
THEIR OWN LAWYER, AND A LAW
FIRM THAT RAISED OVER HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES IN OVER $50,000
PER KEITH ELLISON HIMSELF.
>> Tucker: THAT IS NOT
LEGITIMATE.
KAREN, YOU HAVE SAID, ALLEGEDLY,
THERE IS A VIDEO THAT SHOWS YOU
BEING DRAGGED OFF THE BED BY
KEITH ELLISON, HIM SWEARING AT
YOU.
IT DOES THAT DO EXIST?
>> YES.
>> Tucker: WILL THE PUBLIC
HAVE A CHANCE TO SEE IT?
>> OF THE PUBLIC WILL NOT HAVE A
CHANCE TO SEE IT.
THAT IS MY PAIN, AND FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, FOR
EVERYONE TO LOOK AT AND BOGGLE
OVER, SOMETHING THAT VERY
TRAUMATIZING FOR ME,
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I WOULD NOT ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
SEE IT.
IF AND WHEN I DECIDE TO SHOW IT
TO SOMEBODY, IT WILL BE IN MY
TIME.
THIS IS A PROCESS.
AND JUST TO FIND THE COURAGE TO
COME OUT AND BREAK MY SILENCE,
AS I SAID, KNOWING THE BACKLASH
THAT I WOULD GET AN KNOWING THAT
THIS IS A JOURNEY THAT I WOULD
WALK PRETTY MUCH ON MY OWN, IT
TOOK A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
COURAGE.
AND I HAVE TO FACE THE SAME
FEARS THAT SO MANY OTHERS WHO
HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED FACED WHEN
THEY DECIDED TO EITHER SHARE
THEIR STORY OR NOT SHARE THEIR
STORY.
IT IS ALSO THE SAME KIND OF FEAR
THAT MANY PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
KNOW ABOUT THE SITUATION, HAVE
KNOWN ABOUT IT LONG BEFORE I
EVER SHARED -- WENT PUBLIC WITH
IT -- WHY THEY SIT SILENT.
OR THEY ARE AFRAID TO SHOW
PUBLIC SUPPORT.
MANY HAVE BEEN BULLIED AND
INTIMIDATED, IF THEY DID COME
OUT AND SHOW ANY KIND OF PUBLIC
SUPPORT, AND I GRAPPLED WITH
THAT SAME FEAR.
THE FEAR OF ISOLATION, THE FEAR
OF BEING RE-VICTIMIZED.
>> Tucker: THAT IS NOT WHAT
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO FEEL,
ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MAKING YOU FEEL THAT WAY.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING A